[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du cetud culture et tout
de suite le sommaire de ce mardi 29
janvier un rendez-vous maintenant
installé à montigny le bretonneux l'
orchestre symphonique répète pour le
concert annuel de la musique classique
mais aussi des compositions pour films
seront à écouter du fantastique de
l'humour et de la poésie les étudiants
du conservatoire de versailles grand
parc seront sur la scène du théâtre
montansier ils compteront l'histoire
d'un jeune soldat qui en contre le
diable accompagnés de jeunes talents et
les faire monter sur scène le tremplin
des voix revient pour sa quatrième
saison des artistes en herbe qui
chanteront à magny les hameaux le 9
février prochain
ils répètent depuis plusieurs mois
quatre formations vont se partager la
scène de la ferme du manet les élèves du
conservatoire de montigny le bretonneux
proposent leurs concerts symphoniques ce
dimanche
marylène yapi finaux a assisté à l'une
des toutes dernières séances de travail
[Musique]
suite numéro deux dans ses airs anciens
d'orchestre les élèves répètent une
composition d'ottorino respighi chef
italien du 20e siècle
ils font partie de l' orchestre créé
chaque année par le conservatoire de
montigny le bretonneux
on essaie d'avoir une programmation qui
est plus varié possible à la fois pour
le public est à la fois aussi pour les
élèves pour qu'ils puissent jouer
différents différents styles alors au
programme on a des oeuvres de schubert
mais aussi une musique
de bons originale d'un compositeur
georges delerue qui était composée pour
le film game bien fou près de quarante
musiciens élèves et professeurs du
conservatoire font partie de l'orchestré
symphonique 5 à 6 répétitions sont
nécessaires pour se coordonner et
surtout découvrir leurs chefs
d'orchestre invités pour l'occasion
cette année ils sont dirigés par
laetitia trouvé il faudrait une couleur
met du rouge vous mettez quelqu'un d'un
peu plus velours voyez ça nous paraît
texture on est laetitia trouver des
réviseurs quesque du concepteur de
vincennes et aussi des orchestres
professionnels bien évidemment les
élèves se prennent au jeu et c'est aussi
une grande importance d'avoir un chef
invité d'avoir pour les élèves une tête
nouvelle à chaque fois parce que c'est
des exigences différentes et c'est un
peu comme les gros orchestre qui ont des
orchestres invités qui change de chef
mais là les élèves aussi change de chef
d'orchestre conclure à une après-midi de
concerts à montigny le bretonneux des
harmonies et des orchestres à cordes et
à vent seront aussi à découvrir
[Musique]
et pour en découvrir encore plus sur ce
prochain concert symphonique marylène
heye à pishin on reçoit antennes gauche
dans son statut de loisirs de ce jeudi
célébrer les arts et la culture le
week-end dernier c'était la sixième
édition de la nuit des conservatoires
des rendez-vous était programmé dans
toute la france avec un nouveau
participant saint quentinois le
conservatoire de maurepas a choisi
d'ouvrir ses portes durant deux jours
nicolas landry pour les images
[Musique]
des boléros des danses bulgare tous les
styles tous les instruments étaient à
l'honneur samedi soir le conservatoire
de maurepas a participé pour la première
fois à la nuit des conservatoires pas
richesse de la diffusion c'est faire
aimer la musique à tous les publics et
avoir une proximité et crée vraiment une
union avec le public
en fédérant un répertoire attractifs et
diversifiés
une première participation en mode grand
format de soirée et trois lieux
culturels différents de la commune
l'objectif est de montrer le dynamisme
et toute la créativité qui au sein de
présente aux saintes de ce conservatoire
de mettre en valeur les élèves les
petits aussi bien que les grandes
équipes puissent se mettre en scène dans
des conditions qui sont quasi
professionnelle une quinzaine de rendez
vous les artistes en herbe ont pu
présenter le travail d'un trimestre
j'étais stressé parce que va se ma
première fois mais c'était cool parce
que j'avais mes amis ma famille elle
chante super bien c'est la meilleure et
puis bah il y avait aussi ma fille qui
chantait donc pour moi c'est tout
bonheur j'ai pu la découvrir
différemment
et j'ai vu qu'elle était aussi soutenu
par tous les gens qui étaient là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le site créé en 1972 accueille
aujourd'hui environ 600 élèves répartis
entre la musique et le théâtre la
musique est signée igor stravinsky le
livret charles ferdinand ramuz l'oeuvre
composé en 1917 et sur la scène du
théâtre montansier à de versailles à la
mise en scène renaud rivière qui est
avec nous au plateau ce soir
bonjour bonjour alors l'oeuvre raconte
l'histoire d'un soldat qui rentre chez
lui ont perdu sur l'ex au violon il
rencontre le diable tout à fait alors
c'est une effectivement une histoire
inspirée des contes daf anna sieff dans
les comptes de la faim acf on a souvent
des gens qui s'amusent avec le diable et
le diable étant à la fois un prince est
un bouffon sont des histoires plutôt
poétique et drôle en même temps et c'est
le cas de l'histoire du soldat donc on a
un soldat qui rencontre le diable et le
diable ressemble à quelqu'un de normal
voire un peu d'effet
il lui propose un troc qui est
d'échanger le violon du soldat contre un
livre mais pas n'importe quel livre un
livre dont on tire des titres des
billets de l'or sans même savoir lire
alors le soldat d'abord est perplexe
puis il accepte et et grand mal lui en
prend puisque après ça va en fait le
violon est le symbole de sa joie de
vivre de ce qu'on peut rencontrer dans
la roue dans la création dans le fait de
s'épanouir par la musique par exemple
et du coup il va perdre sa joie de vivre
et il va tout faire dans la suite de
l'histoire pour essayer de récupérer son
violon qui est le symbole de son âme
aussi alors pourquoi vous avez choisi de
le mettre en scène c'est un projet qu'on
vous a proposé ça vient exactement
en fait c'est une commande du de la
communauté d'agglomération versailles
grand parc qui voulait un projet pour le
conservatoire ce projet il est porté par
david silver ce qui est le chef
d'orchestre et qui est le premier violon
du spectacle l'idée c'est que comme
l'oeuvre a été jouée en 1917
en fait elle a été non pas jouer en 10
17 elle a été créée en 1917 est joué
en 1918 c'est les 100 ans de l'histoire
du soldat et donc on a voulu marquer le
coup et david su vers sa lancée cette
proposition qui est très ambitieuse
parce que c'est une oeuvre qui mélange
les styles les genres qui est très
étrange très poétique très onirique très
moderne
c'est l'oeuvre de 1917 que vous
présentez vous à les honorer
elle a eu plusieurs
plusieurs suites cette oeuvre dire que
d'abord il a écrit une suite pour
clarinette violon et piano
et puis en 1920 il a écrit la suite
qu'ont acquis édité chez suz hester qui
est une suite pour vents cordes et
percussions et ram usa a écrit le livre
est qu à partir de 1918 en réalité le
spectacle il était prévu pour être joué
dans les villages suisse mais comme
c'était la guerre et qui est la peste
ils ont abandonné l'idée donc on nous
ont fait la version de 1920 qui est dure
une heure cinq équipes une bonne
composition entre la musique et le texte
et l'entrecroisement des deux vous le
disais tout à l'heure c'est une commande
de versailles grand parc et sur scène on
retrouve des étudiants du conservatoire
exactement alors donc il ya sept
musiciens dont david silver ce qui lui
est par un étudiant un grand violoniste
et trois comédiens qui sont des élèves
du conservatoire que j'ai dirigés et au
début je me disais que c'était trop
difficile en fait pour des élèves du
conservatoire je me suis dit comment ils
vont faire
j'ai accepté le projet parce que c'est
sa rencontre mon univers j'ai monté
faust mais j'ai monté aussi pas mal
d'auteurs russes
gogol boulgakov donc je trouve le
croisement intéressant et en fait ils
avaient raison parce que ces virtuoses
mais et mais ça nécessite une grande
souplesse et je crois que les jeunes du
conservatoire ils ont encore cette
souplesse que les vieux acteurs aguerris
au moins est par ailleurs cette cette
jeunesse qui l'ont elles portent un
enthousiasme et une vie sur scène qu'il
a été qui a été trouvée très vite et qui
est très joyeuse équipe qui donne un
éclairage beaucoup plus dynamique
beaucoup plus claire à cette oeuvre qui
sinon peut très vite être
trop sombre alors ses chances les plus
accessibles peut-être pour le jeune
public aussi vous allez faire des
représentations scolaires et l'idée
aussi c'est que c'est incroyable de
pouvoir proposer une oeuvre avec cette
comédie avec sept musiciens et trois
comédiens sur scène c'est à dire quand
même un gros effectif à des dans des
conditions qui sont abordables pour tous
dans l'optique d'un théâtre populaire
donc là on joue devant des scolaires
mais on joue devant des tous publics
devint très vite et c'est possible parce
que c'est le conservatoire parce que ce
sont des gens qui sont en fin de
formation professionnelle et qui sont
pas payés et c'est pour ça qu'on peut
proposer des places à 5 euros au public
scolaire est à 10 euros tout public
sinon quand s'est joué à l'opéra vous
imaginez les prix sont beaucoup beaucoup
plus élevé ben il il ya la technique la
logistique cela nécessite des moyens ça
nécessite une place qu'on a parce qu'on
est au théâtre montansier mais ça
nécessite surtout des interprètes qui
sont assez solide on a la chance d'avoir
un très bon conservatoire à versailles
qui est un des meilleurs en france est
de pouvoir proposer ça mais c'est un
compromis qui est sur le fil et qui est
du coût qui est rare est précieux et
tout ça qui présage une bonne
représentation merci robert gilbert
d'avoir accepté notre invitation alors
l'histoire du soldat est à voir ce
mercredi 30 janvier au théâtre
montansier de versailles la séance est à
15 heures la femme et le sport au coeur
d'une exposition ces deux thématiques
ont été proposés à des ânes
un photographe du en courtois par la
ville présentait pour la première fois
en 2018 pour la journée nationale du
droit des femmes
l'exposition est aujourd'hui visible
dans des gymnases l'ancien athlète de
haut niveau s'est attaché au mouvement
photographiant les adhérentes de
diverses associations
ces clichés sont à découvrir ou à
redécouvrir jusqu'au 5 avril
à chaque sport tas a été une découverte
un défi une technique d' approche une
technique d' approche non j'ai pas eu de
sport favori pour un pont pour faire ces
photos ça et c'est vraiment la
découverte et à chaque fois c'est
beaucoup plus gênant pour une femme de
se faire regarder en train de faire des
mouvements doivent se sentir est ce que
je le fais marrer ce que je fais pas mal
surtout qu'en fait c'étaient
principalement tout des novices il ya
aucune atteinte aux clubs professionnels
sur c'est sur ces photos on reparle
musique qui fait aussi partie de
l'histoire de cette notion le musée
d'archéologie nationale on a fait une
visite musicale une physicienne une
chanteuse guide le public durant une
heure a rendez vous à découvrir chaque
premier dimanche du mois regarder
coline et anne-cécile sont des guides un
peu particulière leurs livres d'histoire
est rempli de notes de musique est long
mais ne public dans une visite musicale
du musée d'archéologie nationale
la musique étant l'un des universaux de
notre humanité redécouvrir les
collections avec le prisme de la musique
était plutôt intéressant sachant qu'on
est en plus quelques instruments sein de
notre musée et s'était du coup
l'occasion de se rencontrer d'échanger
et de partager autour de deux thèmes
communs qui sont la musique est aussi
finalement nos origines
pour ce nouveau projet le musée a fait
appel à l'ensemble calliopée un ensemble
d'artistes accueilli en résidence cette
visite musicale spécialement conçu pour
dialoguer avec les collections l'idée
c'est de reprendre ce fil conducteur de
respecter l'histoire que proposait que
raconte le musée mais de prendre la
thématique du monde sonore depuis les
pierres les silex depuis les feux
d'historique ce qui sont ici c'est un
miracle ou qu'elle soit là et de se
l'approprier pour se dire mais ça ce
sont mes origines chanteuse et
musicienne font découvrir des morceaux
oubliés mais garde en tête les grands
noms comme mozart ou de lui si je trouve
ça très intéressant très agréable à la
fois de pouvoir voir des vrais
instruments dans les vitrines
et puis d'écouter de la musique
d'être guidé comme ça par la part des
flûtes j'ai vraiment bien aimé c'est
extraordinaire on a vraiment rêver dans
différentes époques
c'était vraiment magnifique pour moi une
visite originale qui s'inscrit dans le
programme c'est mon patrimoine à
découvrir qu'on soit mélomanes curieux
chaque premier dimanche du mois
des visites qui sont suivies d'un
atelier sonore catherine boni chanteuse
et pédagogue de la voix vous fait
découvrir un instrument ou détient tous
la voix est cet atelier dure une heure
la voix il en est aussi question avec
nos nouveaux invités m'ont rejoint au
plateau audrey bout et neil sadoun
bonjour à tous les ans georges alors
nous allons parler ensemble du tremplin
des voix puisque le 9 février prochain
c'est la quatrième édition du tremplin
les participants ont peu participé
notamment stages de week end dernier
baisse car ils sont tous pressés sa ba
en tout cas ce que j'ai vu ce week-end
s'ils approchent c'est très intéressant
pour eux de plonger là pendant deux
jours complets dans dans la proche de ce
qu'ils vont devoir mettre entre en place
on va dire pour faire de la scène pour
être sur scène pour interpréter pour
voilà chanter juste dans la justesse des
motions etc etc alors c'est un tremplin
vous en êtes le responsable
la responsable dont le but est
d'accompagner et de conseiller les
artistes en herbe ne pas les jeter sur
la scène et oui en fait on a vraiment de
tout parce qu'on a des des artistes ou
des candidats pour qui c'est vraiment la
première fois qu'ils font
un tremplin un casting d'autres à 20 il
écume un peu tous les tremplins de
france voilà mais l'objectif peu importe
le niveau et le temps qu'ils ont
l'expérience qu'ils ont on va dire c'est
de pouvoir les accompagner sur le chemin
dans le chemin où ils en sont on va dire
justement pour s'améliorer pour
connaître un petit peu leur donner les
clés pour pouvoir pour pouvoir partager
avec le public pour pouvoir mieux
chanter pour pouvoir et on a combattu un
accompagnement qui va jusqu'au dernier
instant ce que vous êtes le présentateur
de la soirée et je me dis même sur scène
la dernière seconde vous êtes présents
pour les soutenir
et bien en fait on se rend pas compte
mais dès l'instant où
le jeune chanteur rendre sur scène
puisqu'il y en a beaucoup c'est
quasiment leur première scène comme
comme audrey a pu le dire il ya vraiment
des novices et d expérimenter et on sent
vraiment l'attention chez chez les
jeunes ou les moins jeunes jusqu'aux
jusqu'à la dernière minute dont il faut
trouver le mot juste pour le lancer puis
le mettre en confiance ça que la journée
juste avant le tremplin et ben on est
avec eux on les aide audrée les coachs
au niveau vocal et dernière petite mise
au point et puis moi j'essaye de savoir
un peu plus sur leurs expériences sur
leur vie sur ce qu'ils font à côté aussi
parce qu'il ya pas que le champ et puis
voilà et puis les lancers puis après
c'est parti puis ils se rendent tous
contre et après c'était trop vite quand
ils veulent ils veulent rester sur sa
liste
alors on l'a dit en accompagnement de la
voix mais j'imagine qu'il ya pas que ça
il ya peut-être la présence scénique
fait c'est un accompagnement vraiment
complet le jour j on est trois coachs du
coup il y en a un qui nous rejoint cette
année donc il ya lucidité la coach scène
aussi metteur metteur en scène ici
metteuse en scène il ya moi qui suis
coach vocal et scénique et puis il y a
claude céline qui jusqu'à maintenant
était dans le jury et qui cette année a
rejoint l'équipe des coachs côté de la
voilà la passe de l'autre côté est donc
cette année pour pour 22 candidats on en
a bien besoin de troie parce que la
journée très chargée
il ya les musiciens le coaching les
balances ya tout dans la même journée
puisque c'est un show en live quand même
un 22 candidats alors ça fait 8 c'est
chez les moins de 16 ans il ya des
catégories 7 chez les 17 ans et plus
cette aussi chez les auteurs
compositeurs interprètes
il a fallu faire un choix avant
j'imagine c'est ça c'est dur très dur
très dur parce que cette année encore
plus que les autres années
les candidatures ont explosé donc quand
on en a eu 150 d'habitude voiture à 22
pour réduire à 22 pour réduire à 22
cette année on a on a une nouveauté
c'est qu'on a fait une audition qui
avait eu lieu le 1er décembre à montigny
donc à la salle jacques brel où on a eu
60 candidats et du coup ça nous a aidé
un peu plus ça à faire nos choix parce
que 98% des candidats sélectionnés sont
des candidats qui ont fait l'audition
alors ça va être sur une soirée comment
ça va se passer
cette sortie descriptif pour donner
envie de me dépasser et ben et ben alors
je ne sais pas si cette année on va on
va réitérer mais je crois que oui en
fait il ya les anciens gagnants donc des
années précédentes qui viennent et qui
commence la soirée parce que commencer
la soirée pour le pour le premier
c'était moi ça doit être les jeux qu'on
voit la hacker mondial et fait partie de
vos emails feu donc voilà et ensuite
donc il ya je ne sais pas si si on l'a
vu dans le reportage mais il ya un
système de vote par téléphone donc tout
le public participe en fait à la soirée
c'est ça qui est super intéressant et il
faut leur expliquer donc ça passe par
par voilà pour un départ un début de
soirée comme ça et puis après ça se
lancer puis après petit à petit il ya
des jeux dans le courant de la soirée
pour gagner des places pour gagner des
voix là on essaye de faire participer un
maximum le public parce que c'est super
important
on présente les jurys aussi qu'ils vont
faire partie de la soirée
donc on a des professionnels qui
viennent on a n'a vraiment des gens que
ça commence à intéresser c'est tant
mieux pour le tremplin
et puis à la fin de la soirée il ya le
résultat des votes tant attendu et puis
on a trois prix 4 3 de prix le prix du
jury et le prix du public c'est à dire
que les votes que je publie un vraiment
son new deal à sa place voilà exactement
le le le
les votes du public sont toutes
catégories confondues donc qu'ils
sélectionnent le candidat qui les a le
plus marqués il ya les mêmes critères
que le jury dont qui vote de la même
manière et donc le système de vote c'est
vraiment ces quatre critères c'est un
peu comme l'accompagnement est ce qu'on
attend d'un artiste complet c'est-à-dire
la scène
enfin l'expression scénique la présence
la voix et l'interprétation et l'émotion
donc il ya quatre critères vous nommiez
les anciens notamment saison alors
est-ce qu'elle sera là samedi et les
âmes ailleurs mais ça au parcours qui
doit inspirer elle est passée par the
voice derrière oui alors et léa elle
était justement cette année dans le
comité d' écoute donc elle a fait partie
de celles qui ont sélectionné parce que
justement cette année on a voulu innover
un peu on appris des anciens en plus de
professionnels mais des anciens qui ont
fait partie de ce jury écoute on va dire
qu'ils étaient là l'audition qui ont
sélectionné les candidats
et puis elles ont aussi chanté ce jour
là du coup elles ont pu voilà pour le
bourreau pour le tremplin il sera là
dans public je pense mais pas forcément
en soutien qu'on va forcément sur scène
il y en a tellement qu'il faut pouvoir
un peu et puis aussi quand même
souligner autre chose c'est que cette
année puisqu'on n'en a pas parlé tout à
l'heure on sera logiquement en direct
sur youtube pendant toute la durée du
concert voilà et ça veut dire que des
gens à l'étranger même parce qu'on a une
candidate réunionnaise donc ils pourront
la voir en direct et puis il votait
aussi selon les critères que de réussir
de l'avion ça se complique et ouais
voilà et c'est quand même c'est quand
même pour pour voilà on est une petite
association du 78 c'est génial que on
puisse avoir ce rayonnement là et voilà
et puis il ya des gens on l'a pas dit
tout à l'heure non plus mais il n'ya pas
que des n'y a pas que des franciliens
dans le temps dans les gens qui y
participent
voilà il ya des gens de marseille
de l'isère du nord fin voilà il ya des
gens d'un peu partout et c'est ça qui
est génial quoi et pour découvrir tout
ça le plus simple c'est de se rendre le
9 février à magny les hameaux à
l'estaminet
merci à tous les deux d'être venu en
plateau je rappelle est respectivement
responsables et présentateur du tremplin
des voix et on passe maintenant à notre
page agenda
[Musique]
un conte pour enfants transformé en
conte musical joachim latarjet revisite
le célèbre joueur de flûte de hamelin la
flûte devient trombone pour une
invitation tendre et joyeuse où le chant
la musique et le rire ont des pouvoirs
enchanteur première représentation le 30
janvier à 15 heures elle est l'une des
icônes d'égayer ses plus grands titres
l'école est finie vous les copains les
rois mages sheila et cette fois
accompagné d'un groupe pop rock pour une
réorchestration de ses plus grands tubes
à écouter au théâtre espace coluche de
plaisir un avant goût
[Musique]
si les
et
très bas
tu me du lb le pen
et je tombe r
[Musique]
pourrir direction le prisme d'elle en
cours pour découvrir un artiste du
programme jeunes talents humour
reda c'est dit qu'ils livrent une
déclaration d'amour à ses deux patries
la france et l'algérie deux dates les
1er et 2 février aux clayes-sous-bois
c'est un concert classique qui vous
attend le concert idéal conduit par
marianne piketty qui vous entraîne dans
les quatre saisons de buenos aires
d'astor piazzolla et celle d'antonio
vivaldi un savoureux mélange jouer sur
la scène de l'espace philippe noiret ce
vendredi 1er février
amateurs de danse rendez vous à la ferme
de bel ébat de guyancourt dans la
mécanique des ombres trois danseurs
acrobates mêle danse hip hop et arts du
cirque contemporain des constructions
mécaniques des gestes acrobatiques qui
se rencontrent aussi par la chute
regardez
[Musique]
en ces temps hivernaux envie de chaleur
peut être alors à la batterie de
guyancourt vous propose une soirée aux
consonances jamaïcaine trois artistes et
groupes se partagent la scène et je vous
propose d'écouter l'un d'entre eux dans
les imprimés en scène
[Musique]
c'est la fin de ce site une culture
merci de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve
pour un nouveau numéro mercredi prochain
[Musique]